oh I don't play video games no more
never play video games except for a
little bit of God of War never play
video games
hope people are having a lovely evening
and hopefully I am coming through
clearly
we shall see
yay I am seen I am perceived
ah I'm experienced by others and
therefore my existence is provable by
outside observation and I'm not merely a
mind floating endlessly in the void
hope everybody had a lovely weekend
ah
honor our LGBT Elders Day Out
how do I can do I get considered an
elder
like I suppose it depends on who you ask
there's definitely there's definitely
plenty of people on Tick Tock who would
consider me an elder because
that freaking platform excuse
Young
uh oh first time here well good to have
you here Autumn Rose a reminder while I
do try and keep up with the chat and we
take a nice relaxed attitude uh I cannot
guarantee that
um I will see or address your question
or comment the best way to guarantee
that is a Super Chat which will also
get you a heart from me in appreciation
so yeah don't really have a specific
topic uh this time around
it's just uh
just having a hard time we're believing
believing that we're halfway through May
like this this year is speeding fast at
a at a rate that is
and frankly unsettling to me uh a little
bit
if I'm uh if I'm gonna be honest
uh Loki season 2 is getting released in
October now I wonder why
well
I would say Rowan if you are implying
that it's because of Jonathan Majors I'd
say it's more likely because of the
writer's strike
um
if they're
you know working in the editing room and
they realize that they have
pick up shoots or anything like that but
it could easily be both
I'm just happy we got to hear you're
talking about zathras again this week on
the podcast ah zathras
oh he's wonderful
I mean is being an elder LGBT is
measured by your age or when you
transitioned I don't know
I would think they were both Factor
in
but also like
I don't know how to measure
you know when I transitioned or when I
came out I can tell you how long I've
been on specific hormone cocktails I can
tell you when I when I came out to
somebody in the first place at all I can
tell you when I came out to my mother I
can tell you when I came out to most of
my friends I can tell you when I came
out on the channel I can tell you when I
came out
um on my public facing
um
social media where it was not already
known I can tell you where I oh well
where I would have come out on the job
of that if I hadn't been laid off so
yeah there's that's the thing about
coming out people like when did you come
out like which time
that's a continuous process
yeah the review of Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 that review has ruffled
some feathers which
uh I thought might happen I'd really
hoped it wouldn't
but some people some people's feathers
were very very ruffled by that so yeah
Erin thank you so very much for the
Super Chat I appreciate that greatly oh
Canadian dollars hello my neighbor to
the north
depending on where in Canada you are
probably closer to me than a lot of the
folks in the chat who are in the US are
just saying hello well hello to you as
well
my weekend consisted of being a little
disappointed but ultimately not
surprised that Germany came in last
place at the Eurovision song contest
oh well what can you do
uh
hahaha
qualify as an elder queer carowind I
mean I I think you would wear that title
with wonderful and amazing dignity
would I ever try to do stand up again
not unless somebody paid me
like I um
I could definitely
um see uh
you know see getting having a reason
like stand up and like give a talk give
a conversation I would probably sprinkle
in jokes if I were to do that just
because
I'm me and if I'm not angry ranting then
I'm probably slipping a few jokes in if
I'm scripting
um
but like the idea of doing it primarily
for the purposes of making people laugh
that's not something I do voluntarily if
somebody like wanted to pay me like the
co the price of a speaking engagement to
do a stand-up set yeah sure I do that
but other than that no
do I know John uh campia
I I know I've heard that name
no I don't know who that is
Nova Scotia so yeah not far from you so
oh funny thing uh Aaron the
the job that I had when I was in college
I worked at Barnes and Noble I started
out shelving uh the books and there was
a woman there she worked primarily with
The Used Books
um I forget what her
full name was but her nickname when
everyone called her was Scotia
and apparently before I started working
there they had an employee named Nova
so
yeah that was that was the thing that
happened
oh hey Meg good to see you I'm glad you
came in
Finland should have won Eurovision I
have no opinion I did not watch
Eurovision
I was a British person I've always
thought having land borders must be
surreal like there's just these people a
few miles away who live in another
country
see for me it's surreal to to think
about
the idea of
of uh not being able to drive out of
your own country you know you got to get
on a boat or get on a plane so you know
it varies with what you consider to be
normal and what feels normal to you
have I ever watched a soap opera before
depends on how you define it
um if you mean the way most people would
Define it like a daytime soap opera no
have I
watch some shows that are effectively
like soap operas with better production
value like say for instance Ugly Betty
yeah I have so you know it depends on
how much you want to stretch the
definition
Amanda j m b thank you so much I'm
closer to 50 than 40 and proud of Elder
status yeah like I am finding the older
I get like once I once I started
approaching 40 and I accepted that I was
almost 40.
um I was like you know what
you know what
that's 40 years
uh during which I have not
um let the world grind me down
that's that's a badge of honor that is
so
yeah
I get more comfortable with it as as I
age which makes sense one would hope
maturity would make you more comfortable
with your actual age
Tobin Jordan
thank you very much for the Super Chat
let's see
uh Hey I just uh saw you were live on
here wanted to say hi saw you performed
last Friday night with my friends and
you were amazing just wanted to say
hello and thank you thank you Tobin I
think this might be the first time
someone who has seen me uh perform live
has popped in during a live stream
lovely I hope you had a good time that
was a fun show I did another show the
very next night uh in Rutland but I
always like performing at untapped it's
uh it's a real fun venue I um
handed up with a
not insubstantial bruise uh on my knee
from my first number
uh from when I jumped down and stabbed
the uh the phone I I didn't land uh
exactly as I should have
um and people
people who don't know what kind of
performance I do or who I've never seen
me perform live which is the vast
majority of the chatter just like
she just says stab a phone wait what
yeah well
burlesque takes many a form
do they have soap operas in the US I
mean yeah they're not like they were
huge for a long time they're not as much
of a thing now
um but there's probably still some going
wouldn't be surprised if they accused
you of hypocrisy hypocrisy for not
liking the element of Guardians of the
Galaxy three yet liking Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy well I point out two
things about that one
I read Guardian I read Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy and fell in love
with it at an age when frankly that
stuff didn't bother me I'm not the same
person
that I was when I fell in love with
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy
and it's easy to retain that love once
you're in it
but even beyond that uh
that book series and really no
adaptation like this and this is okay so
this is the big thing for me when you're
talking large-scale destruction of
anything
in these things whether it be
superheroes or anything else whether you
play it for comedy or you play it
seriously
the instant you establish children
tread very lightly
because the needless and cruel and
unfeeling death of children ticks me off
and part of that is being a parent I'm
sure
but
I understand that it makes no logical
sense when I tell you that if a film or
story does not it does not firmly
establish me that children exist then
I'm able to pretend they don't I
understand they make so logical sense
but that's the emotional reality
if a story does not invest me in the
fact or present to me the fact that
there are children then it becomes a
purely theoretical hypothetical thing
that I can choose to not deal with it's
why I can work with some stories that
have mass destruction in them like
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy like Dr
strangel like the original Star Wars and
the destruction of Alderaan we didn't
see anybody on that planet and some
people might say well you know limit of
the budget and whatever no it was a good
thing we didn't see anyone on that
planet because they're just fodder if
you established me that to me that you
think children are acceptable fodder
I'm not really okay with that and I do
get this is a way bigger hang up for me
than most people I get that
when's my next busy weekend I want to
know when the next Doctor Who trailer is
coming out
uh it feels like most of my weekends
I've got a couple of busy ones in June
pride month big shock
why am I so opposed to RTD and Marigold
and all the producers coming back
um
I'm not in the abstract what I am is
worried I'm not opposed to it but I'm
made nervous by it because no it does
not mean they're going to retread it
but the idea that they aren't going to
retread things was the main thing that
got me excited but it's harder to
maintain that hope when more and more
and more and more elements from before
are brought back in
that hope is not obliterated but it has
shifted into a much greater sense of
caution because there's a lot of
groundwork now there's a lot of
foundation that is the same stuff
doesn't mean it'll be the same thing no
it doesn't I certainly hope it isn't
I want to come out the other side of
this and go I shouldn't have been
worried but I can't change the fact that
I am at the moment
that is not wine Ms Wicked Wolf that is
water
and uh if it appears anything other than
clear check your monitor settings
what am I going to open a P.O box or you
can send you some uh unless I have a P.O
box
it's in the description it's at the
bottom of the description of literally
every video I don't mention it anymore I
used to more often
but I've had a P.O box for years
uh not insignificant amount of stuff
that's on the shelf behind me in every
video was sent to me uh to the P.O box
I've got one check the description
dude
where did I leave off
uh have I have I ever heard of
Coronation Street I have I've never
watched it
I don't think I've ever watched uh
British soap
I'm a fellow burlesque and MC and the
knee drops are brutal yeah
yeah like it could have been worse but
like I can look at the bruise and go
yeah
just wear knee pads I don't want to wear
knee pads because then you can tell I'm
gonna either do floor work or I'm gonna
do a hard knee drop and like it removes
the surprise of the moment but like at
this point I
girl you're 41 put on freaking knee pads
will we see any pictures of your shows
from this weekend uh maybe a little I
mean some of them are including some
backstage things are going up on
another site which I will not mention by
name
um because I still don't really know how
YouTube takes to my mentioning that but
you know the the the one that's
um
exclusively for enthusiasts
uh just with a slightly different
wording uh some pictures are going up
there
um but yeah I mean there'll probably be
some that go up on the Vera wild Twitter
um
I mean if you don't mind a slightly more
risque look at my life that's where that
stuff tends to pop up as far as public
posting
um
let's see
watch a few Spanish soap operas oh
interesting
like your earrings oh thank you
um actually these actually were given to
me this past weekend
um one of my partners gave me these
which was very sweet uh he made them
let's see none of my Parenthood is
showing let it show I'm a parent
like what am I gonna pretend I'm not a
parent and I don't have parental
instincts
uh
hope I didn't get hurt I'm fine it's
just a bruise
yeah I am sorry about that Jen I don't
know what the issue was there
do I watch succession I have not
um I don't know if I'll get around to it
I'd like I'm always behind on this on
stuff that
um I've been meaning to like I there are
things that I've been meaning to see for
literally decades
I'm on loyal fans
yes you are I remember that
um no I've not seen succession I've seen
Clips it seems
lovely it seems like it's uh
it's interesting and compelling and a
good time and uh and all that
is that the only bruise I
think
[Laughter]
oh goodness
I have an interesting life
ah
how do you cope if say one does not have
a reliable support system and lack
personal strength I'm assuming you mean
in terms of
like trying to come out or have a
support system while clear and
unfortunately I'm not in a position to
um answer that
because
um
I
did have a support system and still do
have a support system and I mean
personal strength that I mean that feels
like a bit of a self-deprecation
but I I'm not I don't have the training
to advise someone
when my own experience is so far
away from that
um if you don't have a therapist or
someone with training who you are able
to talk to I would recommend looking
into that
um
but I'd like I had I had support
I can tell you broadly speaking the
thing to do is to try and find support
and it can come in a lot of forms it can
be
select family members friends romantic
Partners it can be an online community
depending on the nature of the support
you need
but it is out there
and as far as lacking personal strength
I think
you probably have a lot more strength
than you realize
but if you're in a situation where your
strength is overwhelmed it can feel like
you don't have any I rarely find it to
be the case that there truly isn't any
there
have I ever watched Peep Show nope I
have not
Amanda jmb coming in back
exclusively for enthusiasts I have to
buy you another drink for that
thank you thank you very much that would
be quiet let others talk hey
it's your dime you can do as you will
it was a character on Coronation Street
who had 30 hour relationships and 30 odd
jobs over their 50-year 10-year I feel
this I feel like shows how ridiculous
active TV characters lives are
um yeah long run I mean this
um
overly sarcastic Productions talked
about this the difference between
plot time and downtime
where how during plot time a ton of
stuff happens in a small amount of time
but then during down time like between
stories it feels like nothing ever
happens or very few things happen
um and so you'll have you know massive
time jumps and characters are basically
the same or they've had like one major
event since the last time you saw them
but during plot time if you actually
like map out how long these characters
have known each other how long they've
been on this Quest or working whatever
and or you know something like Age of
Ultron which is actually like the half
day of Ultron you know that that's the
difference in time compression or like
if you have if you ever run the math on
how many actual days your
um campaigning party in a DND campaign
have have actually known each other it
gets ridiculous in a good way
ah
what happened in Guardians of the Galaxy
that you didn't like it's a bit of a
spoiler Black cover uh the the
um the review is up in the break room
there's there is a uh I'd say around
about middle or two-thirds of the way in
there is a
specific uh thing that
I did not feel was necessary and really
would have preferred that the film not
do if it was not going to give it proper
weight which I don't feel it did and
then I also had a number of admittedly
highly nitpicky like super nitpicky
things but they still took me out of it
so what are you gonna do
you think the 60th uh Doctor Who
specials will have an entirely different
tone from to season 14 onwards
I have absolutely no idea
I mean you need to realize uh Tom Monty
that
um I'm a bad person to ask that kind of
speculation about because my brain
doesn't work that way
um it's very rare that I have any
natural inclination to think about ooh
and then I bet it'll do this and I bet
they're gonna do this and then it'll be
different and they'll do that like I if
I don't have something to base those
opinions on I.E if I haven't seen enough
and like we've seen nothing of series
14.
I can't force my brain to try and think
of that and come up with stuff
um so I'm this is why I'm bad at
speculation because there's a part in
the back of my brain that goes why are
you wasting thinking time on this you
don't have the information you don't
know this is a wild guess it's not even
an educated guess
so I'm a bad person to ask
excuse me
with regards to my viewing of Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 and without going to
detail the moment a certain character
reacted to something else is very
um what is that now spam uh is very
in a very white place was the one I
started crying ah
but I cried at a few points like here's
the thing and like people seem to miss
this
and focused a lot on my criticisms but
like the parts that are good in
Guardians 3 are great
and I admitted to crying multiple times
so yeah
I'm in no contact with my parents 14
years ago found a chosen family a few
years ago I'm glad you found that
pirates I really am
any idea what's with the weird trend of
conservatives being hopelessly sex
negative yet at the same time going out
of their way to pretend Ace and
aromantic people don't exist that's not
new I mean that's just an added
component to an already to an existing
things conservatives by and large have
always been sex negative that's not new
and because asexual and aromantic are
queer identities they're gonna cry
they're gonna slam down on that and
they're not okay with being asexual or
being a a romantic because in their mind
asexual any romantic people don't get
into relationships don't get married
don't get a house with a picket fence
and don't crank out 2.5 kids so yes of
course they have disdain for that
it's my favorite piece of Steampunk
media
um
ah
I'm not sure I've been taking in all
that much actual steampunk media because
it's for me it's mostly an aesthetic
that I like I mean probably girl genius
would probably be it
yeah
black cat came up to my driveway
yesterday her name is Cinder that's a
good name for a black cat
now Black cover I'm I'm not going to
answer that as I said it is uh spoilers
so like you can watch the video and
you'll get an answer for exactly what it
was that happened
uh what I think of Groot I didn't like
what they did with them I didn't mind
what they did with him but he was just
kind of there like he he was not a
focused character he felt very much in
the background but not in a way that I
that I found distracting
uh at any rate
am I at the very least excited for
what's about to come next and Doctor Who
I'm always excited for doctor I can be
excited and nervous at the same time
because I'm not jumping up and down and
going it's gonna be great
I mean I'm not excited
I contain multitudes two things can be
true at the same time I can be nervous
but I can also be excited I am both
so you don't have to ask me I am I at
the very least excited as if my concerns
make me incapable of excitement and joy
they don't they don't and I say that as
an admittedly cynical person but I'm not
that much of a cynical person
huh
John vinyls thank you so much for the
Super Chat still trying to understand
the logic behind why Netflix chose to
cancel dead end paranormal Park probably
just expense
uh it was a bit of a niche show that you
know two years ago was doing well enough
that they would have cleared it but they
are cutting a lot more stuff
um just like all the streaming services
they're they're doing less output
because the Glory Days of oh we're
getting this many new subscribers every
single month those are those days are
gone and so they have to level out their
spending that's why
yeah like they gave this character stuff
to do every season then the mid-2000s
someone wrote an article where they
pointed out this guy had like 30 jobs
I'm sure that was a fun article for
someone to uh
to research you cried as soon as creep
queued up boy that that you you watched
the credits through the opening credits
through Haze then Dharma good Goodness
Me
uh
let's see
what have we got here
chh
and John vinyl is coming in again
on the whole the Guardians movies are
actually a lot smarter more harmful than
they get credit for being and I will
even say that Chris Pratt is a great
actor in those movies he's a great fit
for those movies it doesn't necessarily
make him a great actor
um but he's a very good fit for those
movies and like they're good they're all
good but like there were things about
this one that just weighed on me in a
way I was not expecting
uh the next class the next scheduled
classic who request I'm not going to
tell you that Rowan because that would
be information for the patreon folks
because I had a poll on there and they
decided what it was and I'm not gonna
say what they decided
y'all will find out
I agree with you Meg I agree with you
Karen chosen family is amazing
oh Carolyn just said anyway I mean like
I might as well have said I was kind of
being cheeky uh about that because I
don't think I've ever withheld that
information before like I I generally
like sharing the docket is is a patreon
thing but yeah no it's Keys it's he's a
marinus
um I think I've answered that
straightforwardly before so uh no
worries I was just being a little bit of
a bit of a cheeky bugger with that one
ah
oh well have a good evening cappuccino
thank you for stopping in
how does my excitement for the new era
compared to my excitement for previous
errors I don't know I didn't
I don't
I didn't keep tabs I
comparable I guess I'd like I I Tom the
you're just asking questions that don't
compute with my way of of viewing things
so I'm sorry I'm not giving good answers
uh
I think I cried most of the movie Fair
do you do I think Netflix is just
completely screwed no
[Music]
no I don't I don't think so I mean it'll
it'll shrink it won't be what it was
um as long as they're careful with their
spending which they're
obviously at the very least trying to be
um no they'll still be around
I think they've peaked like these things
tend to do
but no I don't think they're screwed and
like and then they will go away
or they'll be bought out and acquired
God that better not happen
I'm so sick of mergers and acquisitions
[Music]
uh what was the story of the other
Goosebumps book you read
um
the only two I remember reading were
don't go in the basement and
I can't remember what it was called
something about like a monster themed
Carnival or amusement park or something
I don't remember that one I don't really
remember at all I remember reading it
and I say that is in like I remember the
fact that I read it
um
but that's kind of all I've got
foreign
how do I feel about the reduced episode
count for Doctor Who series 14 it was
expected they've been reducing the
episode count steadily for a while I
hope it will go back up if this does
really well but it's unlikely it's very
rare that these things ever go up again
once they have been reduced reminds me
Vera we need to get to Hannah's new
especially yes we do is that out or is
that still on the horizon I cannot I
can't remember when stuff comes out
ah
it's out now isn't it I think it is I
think it is I gotta watch that yeah yeah
now I have not gotten to Muppet Mayhem
uh Ms Wicked Wolf because they dropped
the entire freaking season on me and
then I got intimidated by it I'm like
I've got so much other crap to do
I was really expecting to go Episode by
episode
one day at HorrorLand that was the one
Black cover yeah that was the one
uh
do I actually think the next series of
Doctor Who will be called series 14 or
will there be a tagline like flux
I expect they're just gonna call it
Doctor Who and in official media not
mention the series at all and it'll just
be like the fan designation uh
understanding
um that it is uh that it's series 14. uh
then maybe they'll come or maybe they'll
come up with cute names I don't know
I don't know I mean
it's one of those things that doesn't
really matter until you are marketing it
for sale as a as a Blu-ray or a DVD
because if I were people just watching
it go it's just the new season
why why are amusement parks being scary
such a Trope I would imagine partially
because especially more low rent
Carnival kind of places a lot of the um
a lot of the rides are like really
rickety and feel like they're they might
actually be dangerous to ride and a
surprise number of things have slightly
weird or slightly twisted or slightly
horrific theming to you know things like
fun houses or whatnot it's not that
difficult to think and also like your
traditional Carnival or Fair also
doesn't stay put it packs up and it
leaves
where did they come from where are they
going sense of Mystery
so that sort of thing
uh do you think Disney owns So Many
geeky IPS now it's almost become a
monopoly
no I
Disney
[Music]
owns too much and they have for a while
but all of these Mega companies own too
much
that's not really where the monopolies
are right now the monopolies are in the
tech sector
by and large at the moment
and Renfield needs to be watched yes Meg
we do need to try we need yes we need to
watch that we need to figure that out
uh
Netflix made me mad they cancel all the
great sci-fi shows after one season
because they won't want to pay their
writers well they also don't want to pay
the cost of the show you need to rise
especially with the Sci-Fi show
um those are expensive to produce
so
uh
[Music]
I applied to be a question writer for a
quiz quiz show called pointless
interesting
you may remember that marinus is
referencing your favorite Doctor Who
episode that's relating to the sixth
doctor comic strip reveal uh that vood
became the Cyberman
ah
okay uh-huh
uh John vinyls popping back in sidebar I
know he's not an amazing villain but I
will say that Ronan the Accuser does
work really well as a foil to the
Guardians because they're a
multi-species found family he's
functional as a villain he's
thematically appropriate but you know
he's
also a little on the generic side
um
I was muted son of a gun sorry
that's embarrassing okay
so where did I leave off what were the
questions that I was addressing that
nobody heard me
thank you for uh messaging me about that
Carolyn
if Netflix went bankrupt in our business
what would happen to all the shows I
imagine they'd just be sold off at
auction to try and cover their debts to
whatever IP holders want them
um anyone else excited for Black Mirror
season three I am I just don't know
don't know where I'm gonna put the
reviews all my other reviews for Black
Mirror 3 were
um put in the main Channel but that was
before
um I moved almost all the review
material to the break room of geek so I
don't know where I'm gonna put those but
I am going to do it when they come out
and John vinyls I had an additional
thought on Ronan the Accuser while Ronan
is toxically devoted to the militaristic
legacy of his ancestors and their blood
Feud with zandar uh yeah like I I
understand thematically he fits I just
don't find him that interesting I rarely
find fanatical characters interesting
it's not impossible they can work but by
and large they rarely do it for me
do I expect RTD to stay on after shooty
leaves no I don't ex I don't expect RTD
to last more than one or two series
before he hands it over to someone else
that's been my suspicion for a while
what do I think of Raul and Wendell and
wild don't know I haven't seen it uh the
increased ambiguity of how to correctly
number doctors and seasons is starting
to bug me like God what could be argued
as being the 14th 15th 16th and 17th or
freaking 18th doctor well yeah but you
know there is generally the agreed upon
designation even if technically it
should be something else uh
and there's all yep there's all the
things telling me I was muted
there we go yeah yeah yeah yeah
of course I played Uno Ms Wicked Wolf
anyway
um I've got Discord questions to get to
reminder the Council of Geeks Discord is
a patreon exclusive perk and you do have
the option and the ability to ask me
questions there that I will also address
and stream so I'm going to pop over real
quick I will not be seeing the chat
while I address these
huh
oh geez we got a few I'm gonna try and
burn through these what Shakespeare play
would you like to be in and what
character would you like to play I want
to be in Midsummer Night's Dream and I
want to play Puck would it be a classic
take uh on the play or something
different well my the way I've always
kind of wanted to be involved with
midsummonite stream is to have all of
the US to have
it set you know in the time that it's
set for all the normal human characters
and then all the fairy characters
um be dressed in contemporary Garb like
I want Oberon and a tux
um and uh Puck sort of decked out like
uh you know kind of a punk kind of look
What actors would you want to work with
it and whoever can memorize all the
lines
uh remember a few months back when I
found out that podcaster I liked was
kind of a sex pest to my shame my
instant gut reaction was uh incredulity
that this person I had a parasocial
fondness for could do something like
that because they always seem so funny
and nice do you think that's a big part
of the reason some public figures
particularly people like podcasters and
comedians are able to get away with
being creeps their fans just have uh
incredulity about their public and
private personas being so at odd so
accusations get ignored
um that's a slight oversimplification
but it's a factor I mean if someone has
done a real good job at endearing
themselves to Their audience yeah that
audience is going to give them a lot of
benefit of the doubt and be more likely
to offer them a second chance so yeah
it's a factor sure do you think a fair
criticism of the culture so these are
the e m Banks uh novels both in and out
of universe is the people who live there
can come across as kind of insufferable
because they are one unimaginably
privileged and two very certain of their
own righteousness like one of the books
that I that you haven't read that
accidentally started War uh when they
publicly apologize they caveat with a
historical statistical analysis that
shows 99 of the time what they did would
have turned out well I mean yeah but
like they can't be perfect there's got
to be something wrong with them and I
think arrogance is a very natural thing
for a society like the culture to have I
think that's a fair flaw
I recently found out my baby niece has
loose joints that made me anxious
because uh they're that's very comorbid
with autism
um which I have I can't decide if that
anxiety counts as internalized ableism
in theory I don't think there's anything
wrong with being neurodivergent but I
know our society set it up in a way that
her life will be harder if she turns out
to be on the Spectrum I don't think
that's necessarily uh internalized
ableism I think it's an awareness of her
life being more difficult if that's the
case
like I I'm sure there are plenty of
people possibly even people you know
parents now or people with relatives who
are nervous at the idea that someone
they care about would come out as any
form of queer not because they have a
problem with that but because they know
the world is against them like
caring about and worrying about the
people in your life is not necessarily
some internalized self-hatred
uh all right next set I saw your
documentary on the VR wild today about
spicy accounting is so interesting and
well made looks very professional thank
you where did you get in contact with
the other creators mostly through Tick
Tock
um I'm trying to remember who I had on
there so drugs and I knew from Tech talk
um Katie asaurus I didn't really know
but I was aware of her stuff like some
of these people I was kind of like
mutuals and we'd interacted with before
so drixna and
um Psy I had known before and I knew
through Tick Tock
um
uh Kitty asaurus I was aware of because
of Tick Tock but we never interacted
before she agreed to the interview
leads I'd actually talked with before uh
for Stuff uh on he on the main Council
of Geeks Channel and
um Sean was actually uh I had his
he was pointed out to me by uh Jesse
gender the fact that he did that kind of
content so that I found him thanks to
her because I I like I wanted to round
it out with
um somebody who uh you know uh with a
CIS man somewhere in the group and that
that's where I found him in your
author's diary you said you had one ace
character in dreams of fire I did not
look out for them so I'm not entirely
sure who it is is it chameleon if you
don't mind me asking thank you for the
representation it is not to Malian
chameleon is a very repressed and a very
emotionally cautious character he is not
ace or a romantic
um fair question decent guess like I
would be kind of I part of me would
almost be surprised if you were to Guess
the Character
um that was asexual because it's not
there really aren't any hints and to me
it did kind of inform the way that I
wrote them but I it's there there aren't
like clues or anything in there
do you think it's odd that we haven't
had an attempt to resurrect the old
school pulp cereal Style Space Heroes
like Commando Cody or Flash Gordon I
think a full genre throwback to those
kinds of series will be really
interesting to see in this day and age
if Indiana Jones can still replace and
still replicate the old Pope formula and
people go for it I don't see why we
can't have something like Captain proton
defender of the earth well the thing is
uh they haven't they've failed like I
remember
um
uh when I was in my 20s I was Sky
Captain in the World of Tomorrow that
was a big flop there was John Carter
that was a massive flop you have things
like Strange World from just a year ago
which is doing a lot of its own stuff
but is very much informed by kind of the
Lost World narratives of you know those
kind of exploration you know kind of
things pulpey stories that flopped and
the thing is these these genres in this
day and age are expensive that's the big
thing is that these are expensive to
flop they're not genres that you can
tackle well on a low budget unless you
are trying to be deliberately camp or
going super stylized but even then
that's no guarantee because that's what
sky captain of the World of Tomorrow did
and it flopped so
have you ever heard of a game called
fuga Melody of Steel I have not it's a
2d RPG that's free on Game Pass which
has a really compelling story set in a
world of cat and dog people in a version
of World War II where a group of kids
having to Pilot a tank Fortress to
rescue their kidnapped parents with lots
of deep look at how War can be
an adventure from a kid's perspective
while also showcasing war is hell
that's a fine bounce to ride if they
pulled it off power to them bit of an
alternate Quest alternate history
question here do you think it'd be fun
but I think it'd be fun to have your
thoughts on what if Superman like the
pure classic truth and Justice Superman
existed in the real world but let's say
2010 today how much do you think things
would change that would be entirely
dependent on how willing Superman is to
um Buck the status quo because
you know the
the ideals of the original Superman
Superman was practically a socialist
hero originally every other time he's
like busting up corrupt landlords and
um and stuff like that so
that kind of Superman would have a lot
of problems with the world it is today
and how would things change it would
depend how much he is willing to use his
power to break the system as it exists
and I don't know because that's
generally the question about Superman
how far is he willing to go with the
power that he has and that would be the
big question that would determine how
much things would change would he push
towards them changing yes the question
would be would he force them to change
and depending on what era of Superman
you're talking about he might
celebrate Superman certainly would
that guy was a dick
what is about retconning the Timeless
child that would bother you in a way
that Moffett retconning the end of the
time war in the day of the doctor didn't
um
because I didn't feel like Moffett I
don't feel that that what mafa did it's
technically a retcon but it felt like a
new Evolution of the story it didn't
undo the thing that happened it changed
our
perspective of it but more to the point
it didn't feel like he was trying to fix
a problem
it felt like he had a story to tell that
was the story about saving Gallifrey now
that would be the way to make a retcon
of the Timeless child work is if the
point of it is not to do the retcon the
point of it is you're doing the Recon in
the course of telling a really good
story so let me be clear it's not that
it's impossible to to retcon the
Timeless child and get a good story out
of it it's just that my own instinct is
the odds of you threading that needle
perfectly are so slim I would much
rather people just move forward and we
ignore the thing because if you don't
nail that and I mean nail it
then you've just given more oxygen to
the problem
so
uh what are your thoughts on fan fan
theories that attempt to canonize Peter
Cushing's portrayal of the doctor either
as a pre-hardinal doctor or a doctor
from a parallel universe I I'm not the
kind of fan who needs to do that I can
watch those and fully accept to that
yeah no this is not the same doctor like
too many things just flatly do not fit I
do I the theory that I heard that I like
is that the Peter Cushing Doctor Who
movies are in the universe portrayals of
Adventures the doctor had
um and that that like at the time they
came out the public wouldn't have been
aware that they were basically they were
basically Recreation documentaries
um that's the that's the the way of
fitting them in that I like
uh do you find the way that RTD has so
frequently used the controlling mother
archetype to be problematic or do you
think it's a good way to justify the
companion leaving them to spend time
with the doctor I actually hadn't
thought about that aspect specifically I
can tell you I did get tired of what I
tend to think of as the domestic side of
his stories that wasn't exclusive to him
though there was some stuff with moffatt
that it bugged me with that too but
I I do feel like it's been used as a
go-to a few too many times like you
don't you don't have to make somebody's
home life a mess to give them a reason
to want to travel you know I I I I
generally it doesn't always work because
this was technically the case with Clara
but I generally prefer it when
companions have an active desire as
opposed to are trying to get away from
something
it's one of the reasons I love bills so
much
um okay I'm almost done I promise
or zathras it's zathras emphasis on the
za zathras
you got to roll the r a little bit
zafras
uh
zafiras is used to be Mr burden is a
very sad life will probably lead to sad
death
at least there is symmetry
what are some of your favorite frozen
treats difficulty no Ben and Jerry's oh
you bugger
um
uh I don't know I like the the Magnum
bars
plus I feel a little bit dirty you know
grabbing something out of the freezer to
stick in my mouth that says Magnum on it
um
so I don't know sure I'll go with that
and the heat with the heat of the summer
coming coming what's your favorite
beverage alcoholic or otherwise
whatever
is in the cabinet
I drink water by and large I drink water
I'd I'm boring like that
okay
I am back
uh
any news or any new news or rumors on
the MCU is Fantastic Four besides the
possible gender swapping of Ben Grimm I
didn't even know that was a rumor
groomers uh very much as a rule because
well for the same reason that I
mentioned before I'm I'm just really bad
at uh at speculation like I know that I
I don't for certain know that this is
what's going on and so my brain kind of
wants to stop me from devoting thinking
time
to a rumor that is probably not true I
occasionally tackle rumors if I think
there's an interesting conversation to
be had around it but like just oh latest
rumor like
I can't I can't dedicate my my brain to
it I just can't
Bill Potts got married she would be Mrs
Potts uh only if she didn't take another
person's last name which she might
although like she's also a
piece of sentient space fuel now but
whatever or a piece of glass depending
on where you want to go
excuse me go with it that's not part of
my last question I thought about
including
would you be more worried about your
daughter's future if she turns out to be
queer in some way
um I am
I'm going to politely decline that
question uh 255 A.D simply because I
don't want to get into
my you know even speculative nature of
my kids identity what I will say is I am
afraid for the future for my child and
for all children especially in the US
because
there's a lot of [__]
and I'll leave it at that
have you ever play Fruit Ninja or Angry
Birds yeah I used to play a fair bit of
Angry Birds uh I got over it eventually
but
uh
the new series seasons aren't counting
the Original Series in their numbering
you say original series you mean
original new who or original original
because yeah they've never done that
um
was I a huvian pre-reboot or uh did it
take some time after I got on board
Doctor Who when I saw
um part of the Satan pit when I was on a
honeymoon in London and
um I started and then I got I got home
and I caught up on new Who series one
through three I have been watching
Doctor Who modern era Doctor Who as it
aired since series four
and I've been sticking with it ever
since and you know going back and trying
to take in classic as best I can and
when I can find the time we are going to
wrap it up pretty soon just a heads up
what are my thoughts on the Angry Birds
movie one and two uh the first one was
okay uh the second one was boring to me
you didn't add anything and like what
was good in the first one was still I
was still there but like not fresh
anymore so
oh well what can you do
so let's talk of frozen treats reminds
me I got I gotta reward myself on ice
cream tomorrow I have successfully
survived house sitting on my own for a
whole week
that calls
for a treat
and in fact I would encourage you all
treat yourselves this evening
you have worked hard
you have been through much
and I think
you have all been so very very good
and you deserve
something nice
something
pleasurable
treat yourself to that
that's an order
[Laughter]
oh yes thank you for the reminder uh can
I win 255 A.D thank you for that uh one
last Super Chat much appreciated
all right yeah
ah yes knit and crochet tiger
you don't want to disappoint me do you
um
I have only seen bits and pieces of the
Teen Titan series from 2003. but uh in
any case we are gonna wrap it up there
thank you all so much for joining me
thank you for indulging my silliness and
for spending some time with me
I I really do uh appreciate it I I enjoy
this I enjoy this this time and I enjoy
talking with you folks
so
I hope um
everybody has a great rest of the week
tomorrow
um in the morning 10 30 a.m eastern
daylight time I will be on Twitch and I
will be playing more curse of Monkey
Island
um and
oh tomorrow
marks the return of take two Doctor Who
reviews
I gotta start talking about flux
oh boy
so that's up tomorrow
and this weekend's uh video Saturday's
video will be uh on what I think uh or
how I ranked the entrances and the
introductions and how each companion of
modern era Doctor Who was introduced and
I will be giving my thoughts on what the
worst was what the best was and
everything in between
and that's what is coming up and uh hope
to see you all there
so
take care of yourselves and please
remember that
you're beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
counsel is adjourned
mccavity